throughout this lesson we covered both
paid and free customer acquisition
channels in order to help you determine
what's right for your company at your
stage and development remember to take a
moment to think about where your touch
points are with your customers where do
they hang out in real life and in their
online life you want to make sure to
make them there and don't forget you
don't have to choose just one channel
you can combine multiple channels and
keep learning on the go as long as you
make sure to track your performance and
keep doing only the things that show
positive impact on your goals which is
exactly what we're going to be covering
next lesson tracking and measurements so
we'll see you there